Hi all and welcome to the demo of our
lease abstraction tool.
Once you land on the application,
users can view all uploaded documents
along with their respective statuses.
Filters at the top love for easy sorting
by status,
client age of document and onu ensuring
quick access to relevant information.
Now let's move on to see what happens
when the document is open for abstraction.
On uploading a document,
you can see the status of the document in
queue and also additionally filter to see
what's in progress.
Opening an abstracted document reveals
various tabs on the left side of the
screen.
These tabs group fields into logical
sections for better user navigation.
Each field is accompanied by a page
reference number for quick validation.
When an abstracted field is modified
during validation,
it is moved from abstracted section into
the adjusted section.
This ensures changes are captured and
used to improve the application's
capability overtime.
Once changes are finalized,
users can save updates seamlessly.
To enhance usability,
the application offers 2 viewing modes,
Advanced or Page Wise View for navigating
specific sections and Full Document View
for scrolling through the entire document.
Once all updates are complete,
the finalized document can be exported in
either CSV or PDF formats,
providing flexibility for reporting and
sharing.
For accountability and traceability,
the application includes an audit thread
feature,
which tracks all modifications and
identifies the user responsible for each
change.
Thanks for watching this demo and have a
nice day.